home against the odds
after surviving an ordeal straight out
of the storybooks fisherman Michael
Packard was diving for lobster 45 feet
down in Cape Cod when his day took an
unexpected turn it's just about at the
bottom and I just felt this
truck hit me
and everything just went dark and I
could just feel just
just some hard stuff all around me like
and I just thought did I just get eaten
by a white shark and then I said no I
don't feel any teeth
and I said oh my God I'm in the mouth of
a whale in fact it was a humpback whale
and for 40 seconds Michael was stuck in
its mouth he's swimming and I could just
be in his mouth and he's swimming and
I'm like
this is how you're gonna go Michael
this is how you're gonna die losing hope
he thought about his boys and and the
rest of his family all of a sudden I saw
light and I just
could feel his head shaking and I just
got thrown out of his mouth
into the water or just white water
everywhere as his friend pulled him into
the boat he was in serious pain and
thought the whale had broken his legs in
fact he dislocated his knee and had
other soft tissue injuries but was
otherwise unscathed for son Jacob a text
from his mother was an unexpected
Interruption to lessons your dad was was
diving and a whale just I don't know
attacked him ate him luckily the whale
decided it didn't want Michael for
breakfast after all and he's already
thinking about when he can dive back
into work Emma birchley Sky News